des milliers de manifestants dans les
rues aux abords de times square
alors qu'un couvre-feu a été instauré
dans plusieurs grandes villes
américaines
en réponse aux manifestations violentes
qui ont eu lieu dans la nuit de dimanche
à lundi la mort de georges floyd tué par
un policier à choquer des millions
d'américains
au même moment à washington donald trump
menace encore de déployer les forces
armées si des scènes de pillage et des
modes comme celle de ce week end sont
amenés à se répéter si une ville ou un
état refuse de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour défendre la vie il est
bien de ses habitants alors je
déploierai l'armée des états unis et je
résoudrai rapidement le problème à leur
place
treize mille soldats de la garde
nationale sont actuellement mobilisées à
travers le pays
sur le terrain médico légal la
contestation est également palpable
après une première autopsie contestée
par la famille un deuxième examen
indépendant montre que le décès serait
lié à une asphyxie due à la pression
exercée sur le cou de la victime
l'analyse officielle avait conclu à un
arrêt cardiaque comme causes du décès ce
n'est pas seulement le genou sur le coup
de georges qui a causé sa mort mais
c'est également le poids des deux autres
officiers sur son dos les eaux non
seulement empêcher l'afflux de sang dans
son cerveau mais aussi le flux d'air
dans ses poumons
ceci rend tous les agents présents sur
les lieux pénalement responsable il sans
aucun doute civilement responsable
l'histoire de georges floyd a ému
l'amérique
le frère de la victime s'est rendue ce
lundi sur le lieu de l'arrestation et de
la mort de son frère à minneapolis
lors de ce moment de recueillement
terrance floyd a exhorté les
manifestants à mettre fin aux violences
je comprends que vous soyez tous
bouleversés comme ça a déjà été dit je
ne veux pas que vous soyez aussi
bouleversée que moi donc si je ne
m'énerve pas si je ne fais rien exploser
si je ne salit pas ma communauté
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que vous devez faire
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
vous ne devez rien faire parce que ça ne
fera jamais revenir mon frère les afro
américains ne représentent que 13% de la
population des états unis ils ont
pourtant trois fois plus de chances de
se faire arrêter par la police alors que
la profession est pointé du doigt par
les protestataires
des centaines de policiers de plusieurs
villes américaines ont posé un genou à
terre pour marquer leur soutien aux
manifestants